Hello, hello everybody!
Welcome back to Goodnight Dragoons!
Yes, we are back!
Alright, let me play some Lo-Fi real quick.
Alright, let's see.
Gotta make that a little quieter.
Alright!
Oh my gosh, my voice is so fucked right now.
Cough drops right now.
You know, I didn't stream as much.
I guess it's because I'm not used to streaming super long hours lately.
And I've done a lot of long hour streams this week.
And I haven't really managed to cool down and let my voice rest in a while.
So yeah, during the...
I'm so
needy right now because I was just lying down in bed.
I was lying down in bed and he was on top of my legs.
So I couldn't...
I couldn't move because he was like, like, he was just like being cozy on my legs.
And I was like, I don't want to move.
I don't want to...
No, what is he barking about?
What the fuck is he barking about?
Oh, okay.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right...
I need to check on him.
I don't know what he's barking about.
I'll be right back.
I mean, he's not barking at the door.
That's the thing.
He's just being in attention.
I'm like, can I say that about my dog?
Like, I hesitate a little bit.
I literally, I literally like, um, I, I checked up cause he's like, he doesn't want to sleep on a dog bed anymore.
He sleeps on my bed.
And then, um, I literally went over, checked on him and he's just sitting on my bed and just like...
Like he was just underneath the blankets.
And this was his expression.
Like, he wasn't even like off the...
He was just, he just barked just cause he knows it'll bring me over.
Cause I'm like, what's wrong?
And he was like, got it.
Got her.
Get baited.
Get out of here.
Fuck you, bitch.
Oh my God.
Where was I?
Um, yeah.
My voice is not doing, uh, during the, uh, lockdown protocol.
My voice was not doing so great during some of it.
So, um, so I'm going to...
All right.
For real.
Next week.
It's just going to be Sajab slam streams.
I'm just going to let you guys know right now.
Or N plus one Wooka.
Next week, we're just going to have, uh, Sajab slam streams.
So like during the tournament.
So there'll be like two stream, three streams next week, for real.
For real.
There's going to be three, three streams.
Next week for real.
Only.
Have I practiced yet?
No.
I haven't practiced yet.
I literally, um, I asked like our coach, Brian.
Cause like...
This is what I wrote.
I don't know if you guys know what I wrote here.
I was like...
Let's see.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I literally just spent five moves on King during Tekken Slam.
And I'm playing Modern GeForce Street Fighter.
You have to talk to me in PlayStation controller symbols for me to understand inputs and combos.
I was like, please do not use any actual FGC terminology.
Please speak to me in PlayStation controller symbols.
Because that is the only way I can understand what the fuck I'm doing.
That's the only way.
I was like, what the fuck?
I don't understand the colors.
You know, like in the Street Fighter, it was like...
Left... left...
Left... yellow...
I'm like, what the fuck is yellow?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is...
What the fuck are...
What does red mean?
What the fuck does yellow mean?
I don't know.
Like...
Red equals heavy.
Which one's heavy?
What the fuck is heavy?
So just... just say square, triangle, X, or circle.
Like...
It's time.
If I didn't learn the proper...
Names...
Of my controller...
During Tekken...
I will not need...
I will not learn during Street Fighter.
I'll never learn.
That's the joy of being a VTuber.
I don't know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Yap stream.
Give me the sweet...
Jiminy squirrel words, Miss Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zonderman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God.
You're...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But yeah.
I mean...
I learn pretty fast.
Honestly.
Like...
I don't know...
I'm not tuning my own horn here.
Uh...
But like...
I feel like...
I do learn pretty fast.
As long as like...
I'm given like...
Straight directions on what to do.
Like...
As long as you don't overwhelm me...
On like...
What to do.
I can learn...
Pretty fast.
Like...
You just give me like...
Um...
Just be like...
Just do this.
And I'll be like...
Okay.
And then I just brute force the learning.
I can do long training sessions.
Like...
I can play rank for a very long time.
If I want to.
Um...
Well...
Currently, I don't want to.
So...
Currently...
Currently, I don't want to.
But like...
When I get into it...
Like...
I...
That's how I got into red rank, guys.
You remember?
I think my favorite part...
Like...
One of my favorite parts...
During the...
Uh...
Tekken...
Slam...
Was like...
When...
Uh...
Um...
Other...
Opponents...
My other opponents...
During the Tekken Slam...
Would be like...
Wait...
How did she get to red rank already?
And they're like...
Wasn't she like...
Silver yesterday?
I...
I remember...
I don't remember who said that...
But I remember somebody on...
The enemy team...
Was like...
Out of...
Wait...
I thought she was like...
Silver yesterday...
How the fuck did she get to red rank already?
And...
Uh...
Um...
And like...
It...
Like...
I can grind rank if I want to...
I just...
Like...
I...
I just need to get into the mindset...
I'm not in the mindset at the moment...
Just cause like...
I don't know what I'm doing...
But like...
The moment I start...
Understanding what I'm doing...
Um...
Cause like...
I still don't know what I'm doing...
Like...
Oh yeah...
And then my coach...
Was like...
It's better...
Since you're playing...
Modern Geve...
It's better...
That you don't know what you're doing...
And then I was like...
Okay...
Then I'm not incur...
Like...
I'm not motivated...
If...
If I don't know what I'm doing...
I'm not as motivated...
To like...
Play...
Cause I was like...
Then what's the point...
If I don't know...
So...
Um...
So like...
Yeah...
So I was like...
Well...
Might as well not learn...
Like...
Um...
Haha...
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa...
Thank you...
Hey Doki...
Thanks for another...
Goodnight Dragoons...
Means a lot...
From the one Dragoon you're meeting...
Great...
Thank you...
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa...
I really appreciate it...
Yeah...
So I haven't had...
Um...
I haven't had...
Like...
A lot...
Of time...
To do Goodnight Dragoons...
Um...
Just cause like I said...
It's like super late at night...
Too...
And...
I've been...
Honestly...
I'm...
I'm super behind...
Like...
I...
I am...
I won't...
Lie...
I am very behind...
On a lot of work...
Stuff...
In general...
Because a lot of stuff is...
Has been happening...
Behind the scenes...
At the moment...
Um...
Like...
I had to...
I went outside today...
Hahaha...
I...
I went outside today...
And like...
So like...
I've been doing a lot of...
Meetings...
And like...
A lot of...
Adult business stuff...
Lately...
And...
Um...
So it's been...
It's been really tiring...
I had to wake up at like...
9 AM...
This morning...
Because I had to...
Had a meeting...
Um...
Like an actual...
In person meeting...
Not like...
Not like those like...
In call...
Like...
In call meetings...
Like I had to actually go to an office...
In person...
Today...
Um...
For some...
Super important...
Business meetings...
And everything...
Um...
I'll spoil a little bit...
One of them...
Is that...
Um...
We're...
Uh...
I'm finally...
Moving on...
To...
Trademarking stuff...
So like...
Hahaha...
As I was like...
Oh my god...
It's so...
Oh...
Tiring...
It's really tiring...
Hahaha...
That's like...
It's like...
It's actual like...
Business things...
And I'm like...
And then like...
I was just listening...
And I'm...
And they're like...
Do you understand?
I'm just like...
Yeah...
Hahaha...
I'm just like...
Yeah...
Hahaha...
I understand...
Oh my god...
But...
That's all I'll say...
That's all I'll say about it...
Um...
And...
Oh my gosh...
It's...
Like...
I learned so much about like...
Retainer fees...
And everything...
And then...
Um...
And then they're like...
What do you do?
And I was like...
Entertainment...
Hahaha...
They're like...
So...
I can't be like...
A DA...
Because they're literally like...
Lawyers...
So I was like...
Entertainment...
Hahaha...
They're like...
Okay...
But like...
You gotta be specific...
And I was like...
Um...
Hahaha...
It was...
It was like...
Oh my gosh...
It's so tiring...
I've been through so many meetings already...
Um...
But yeah...
It's been...
Busy...
Going outside...
I hate being an adult...
I hate...
And then they're like...
Ahhhh...
And then...
The lawyer...
Was explaining to me...
About bookkeeping...
And I was like...
What?
They're like...
You need a bookkeeper...
And I was like...
A bookkeeper?
Like...
Yes...
You need a bookkeeper...
To like...
Help with everything...
I was like...
Okay...
Hahaha...
Do you need...
Oh my god...
I need a...
But I was like...
But what does...
What's the difference between...
Bookkeeping...
And...
Having...
An...
An account...
And they're like...
Well...
I...
And then...
One of the lawyer...
The lawyer meeting I had...
They were like...
Well...
Having a...
Like...
Um...
Having a...
Uh...
Account...
It's advised not to have your account...
And do the bookkeeping...
Because it's a lot more expensive...
I was like...
But...
How...
What?
And they're like...
It's better to do it in house...
And I was like...
Math me no good...
Math me...
Math...
Math me no good at...
Number hard...
So...
Yeah...
It's...
Oh my gosh...
I'm just tired...
I said...
So that is why we haven't had...
Good night dragoons...
In a while...
And why I've been like...
Super busy...
Behind the scenes...
And why I've been behind...
A lot of stuff...
Because I've been trying to figure out...
How...
What to prioritize...
And like...
What to prioritize first...
What to do first...
And then...
And then I just...
I...
I fall asleep...
And then I just go to bed...
I can't...
I'm too tired...
Um...
Let's see...
Uh...
Epi...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
A bit late...
But thank you for coming to...
Animangaki Malaysia...
Super glad I got the chance to talk to you...
During the meet and greet session...
Two minutes is way too short...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Epi...
Um...
Yeah...
It's so hard...
Um...
It's so...
Okay...
Oh...
That is not very encouraging...
Had to be my own bookkeeper once...
It is the most terrifying...
And stressful jobs on earth...
That is...
Ooh...
Not looking forward to that...
Well obviously...
I'm not gonna do it...
I'm not gonna...
Obviously...
I'm not gonna be doing that...
Um...
I'm not gonna be doing that myself...
But yeah...
That's why I've been like...
Super...
Up behind on a lot of stuff...
Um...
And like...
Uh...
Yeah...
So...
Everything...
Everything's a little...
Okay...
I won't lie...
It's not a little bit of a mess...
It's a...
Bit of a big mess...
But...
We're gonna...
We're gonna fix it!
We're gonna fix it soon!
I swear!
It'll get better soon!
When everything calms down...
That is...
This is also why...
I am...
Not streaming...
A lot next week...
Because...
Um...
I have to...
Do a lot of stuff...
Behind the scenes...
To catch up...
To fully...
The moving part did not help...
That's for sure...
The moving part...
Actually did...
Definitely did not help...
With the whole...
Being behind on everything...
So...
That's why...
So like...
That's why I'm even more behind...
We can fix it...
I...
I believe...
As long as you guys believe...
Then like...
I believe...
Also the PC issues...
Yeah...
You know like...
Okay...
What's funny was that like...
Hyatt was like...
Do...
Should we just send in one of our own guys...
To like...
Figure this out...
And I was like...
You know...
You...
That would be great...
Because then...
I don't have to like...
Fucking...
Carry this PC to the shop...
So like...
Potentially...
The...
Hyatt people...
Might send...
The PC...
Someone...
Over...
To be like...
What the fuck is going on...
With the PC...
I...
Maybe...
We can fix the PC too...
Um...
So yeah...
So that's basically what's going on...
With my life at the moment...
Um...
Fuzzy...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
I can't believe my tomato...
Oshi...
Has the time management skills...
Of a tomato...
You know...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
I think it just doesn't help...
That everything...
Like...
Um...
Built up...
And then like...
It was hard to catch up...
When so many things...
Kept popping up...
And stuff...
And there's like...
A lot of like...
Um...
Business adulting things...
That I have to do...
And like...
I obviously...
I couldn't like...
Uh...
What's the word...
I couldn't like...
Um...
Stall it...
I have to like...
Focus on that...
And stuff...
And that was like...
Majority of my time...
And everything...
So it's just...
It's been like...
Being a...
Just...
I would say that...
Running your own business...
Has to be one of the hardest things...
I've ever done...
I've...
Um...
But I'm...
Learning...
It is a great learning experience though...
Like...
I'm...
Okay...
With...
Uh...
Making mistakes...
Now...
And using that...
As a learning experience...
To be...
A better adult...
Person...
So like...
Um...
I...
I'm like...
Happy...
With...
It's very stressful...
It may...
Might be like...
Very stressful...
But like...
Um...
Dealing with it now...
Rather than dealing with it later...
And having...
No adult experience...
Um...
I feel like...
You know...
I don't want to get...
Be coddled...
And everything...
I want to be involved...
With these decisions...
Because like...
You know...
Having that...
Knowledge...
And having that experience...
Is like...
Super helpful...
And everything...
Also...
Lawyers are fucking expensive...
Holy shit...
Like...
I learned...
How expensive...
Retainer fees...
Are...
Actually...
Um...
Especially...
In Canada...
Like...
Oh my god...
The retain...
And like...
I need...
So many...
Different lawyers...
Like...
Cause...
Each lawyer...
Is like...
In charge of...
Each different thing...
Regarding...
Like...
Specific stuff...
Because like...
Like...
Some lawyers...
Don't do that...
Like...
Oh my gosh...
Cause it's like...
A specialty and stuff...
I'm just like...
Oh my god...
Like...
So you might see...
A lot of...
Sponsors...
That I'm taking...
Um...
Normally...
I wouldn't take...
Some of these sponsors...
Um...
But like...
Now...
I don't care...
It's more so...
Like...
I was like...
Okay...
This will pay off...
Some lawyer fees...
Raid Shadow Legend...
No...
I'm not...
I don't have a Raid Shadow Legend...
Sponsor...
By the way...
I...
I don't...
Have any...
Raid Shadow Legend...
Sponsor...
I...
Um...
But...
I don't...
I've done it once already...
I don't need to do it again...
I just did that once...
For the meme...
But...
I mean...
If they pay me...
Like...
A lot...
Raid Shadow Legends...
I will sell out...
For $10,000...
That is my minimum...
That is literally...
My minimum...
Raid Shadow Legends...
If you want to sponsor me...
I will sell out...
For $10,000...
I...
It has to be...
$10,000...
American...
That...
That's it...
Okay...
So...
I...
I don't know...
I don't know where you live...
But...
$10,000...
American dollars...
Is like...
$100,000...
Canadian dollars...
That's...
That's a lot...
In Canadian money...
Might not be...
Okay...
I might be like...
Exaggerating...
A lot...
When I say...
$100,000...
It's actually like...
$99,000...
A Canadian...
Just so you guys know...
It's not...
It's the same thing as...
Yeah...
Unusual...
Or pricey...
And...
Yeah...
Can be...
I don't know...
But...
I...
Can be...
It's like...
$20...
$ roy...
Like...
$20...
$25...?
$25好...
...and everything.
It's been, like, learning about the process and all that, like, um, for myself, has been very interesting, and I do, I really like the experience.
Even though, like, I hate that it's super fucking early.
Um, I wish it wasn't that early.
That's all I wish.
I wish, like, adult meetings did not have to be so early.
Um, Spirit, thank you for the 10 gift dishes!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god!
Today, I went to the mall nearby, right after, um, right after, um, uh, uh, the, the, my meetings today.
And then, this is so fucked.
I showed, like, a photo to a friend, and, like, oh my god.
Um, um, and, like, oh my gosh, it was so fucked, because, uh, cause, like, I didn't know this was a thing!
I didn't know this was a thing, now.
I was, like, that's, like, not great.
But, like, I don't know why people do this.
But, cause I haven't been to an actual mall mall in a long time, because, like, who goes to the mall these days?
Uh, but I went to a nearby mall.
That was nice.
It was next to, uh, that was, like, um, not next to, but close to where, uh, I had to go for a meeting.
And there was this thing that people do.
I don't even know if it's, like, something in Canada only.
But it was basically, like, um, you get to park your dogs.
You get to park your dogs at the mall.
But, like, they, like, stuff the dogs in, like, these tiny little, hm, boxes.
And then you get an app, and it locks your dog into this tiny little dog house.
And it's, like, gla- like, and the door is, like, see-through.
And then, like, and then you can see the dogs.
And I was, like, they looked so sad!
I was so, I was so depre- I was, like,
I said!
I wanna show you guys the picture, cause it was actually really depressing.
I was, like, I was, like, no!
Why would you do that?
It was so...
I was, like, it's literally called Pet Parker.
I was, like, what the fuck?
It's...
Cozy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, no, my lunch.
It's... oh, my God.
It's literally... oh, my God.
I was, like, what the fuck?
Okay, I like how, um...
Okay, so, like, I was, like, that's fucked.
It's literally fucked.
Um...
But, yeah, I did not like that.
I did not like that.
Um...
But, it's basically, you...
It's, like, a little... little boxing.
And then... and then they, like...
They just, like, put their dog in a little dog house.
And then you... it's, like, you download an app.
And... no, it's also in Brazil.
Also, rest in peace Brazil, by the way.
Uh...
Rest in peace Brazil.
Because if you guys don't know, um...
What happened in Brazil is that Twitter is gonna...
I don't know if it's banned right now.
But, like, Twitter is gonna be banned in Brazil.
Um...
Because there was a fight.
There was a...
There... there was a fight.
Between... you know... between...
Yeah.
Is...
Do people...
Are people still able to access...
Are people still able to access, um...
Twitter?
They have less than 24 hours?
You know what I thought was extra fucked?
Um...
The fact that, like...
Uh...
Right before the Twitter ban...
Brazilian Miku Hatsune was super...
Was, like...
Um...
Was trending on Twitter.
Like, it went viral in Twitter.
And then, right after Brazilian Miku...
Um...
They decided to ban Twitter.
And I was like, that is so fucked.
That is really...
Like...
I was just like...
Oh my god!
How do you just suddenly ban Twitter right after that?
Right after Brazilian Miku...
This goes against...
This goes against Miku's ideals.
That timing is actually so messed up.
Miku killed Twitter in Brazil.
Leela was like, no.
Nope.
That's so messed up.
Um...
But, yeah.
I thought that was actually...
Uh...
I...
That was actually crazy.
Brazilian Miku did nothing wrong.
Um...
But, yeah.
Uh...
I...
I can't believe it.
Twitter is going to be gone in the entire country.
Uh...
Before TikTok.
Before the TikTok ban in America.
Like, we lose Twitter for Brazil.
Like...
The fact that, like, Brazil loses the social media before America.
Brazilian Miku...
You know, I...
Honestly, I thought TikTok was going to go first.
But, like, no.
Instead...
Out of nowhere...
Like...
Um...
Brazil...
With the steel chair...
Was like...
At Elon...
No.
No more Twitter in Brazil.
Um...
When it hits his wallet, Elon would totally go back crying for forgiveness.
No, he won't.
He won't.
He...
This man has...
This man bought Twitter because of his ego hurt.
Guys...
Do you not...
Do you not remember why...
Elon Musk bought Twitter?
Like...
And...
By the way...
Like...
He got...
He definitely got scammed.
Because...
He got...
He got sold for way...
Way too much.
Um...
But...
Uh...
Ego...
Yeah...
He...
Literally, his ego was hurt.
And that's why he bought Twitter.
Because he...
Twitter was making fun of him.
And then...
Elon was like...
Was like...
I love Twitter too much.
Just quit using it.
I will buy Twitter.
So no one will ever hurt my ego again on the internet.
If I ban everybody that hurts my ego...
Then I'll be unstoppable.
Uh...
Hunter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine that because of this, the next world superpower becomes Brazil.
Because of lack of Twitter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Speaking of Elon...
I saw the wildest...
Wildest tw...
Like...
I saw the wildest tweet about him.
Um..
But like...
There is like a bot...
That follows...
Like...
That tracks who he follows...
And stuff.
And who he unfollows.
And then...
One of the unfollows...
Was that...
Like...
Women that look like grimes.
Who was his ex-wife.
So he unfollowed a Twitter account.
But...
That, like, tweeted about women that looked like his ex-wife.
And I was like, Jesus Christ!
Well, at least he's finally over her.
Like, at least he's finally moved on.
You guys didn't know that?
I thought that was the craziest shit.
I was like, this has to be satire.
There's no way.
Like, there's no fucking way.
Oh, my God.
I was like, there's no fucking way that's real.
But there was no...
There was no, like, what's the word?
You know, like, those, like, Twitter notes or whatever?
It didn't show up.
So I was like, oh, my God, it's real.
I was like...
There's no fact check thing.
It didn't show up.
I was like, oh, my God, it's fucking real.
Yeah, the community notes.
I was waiting for the community notes, but it never showed up.
It never fucking showed up.
This probably... Oh, no, 100%.
You guys know why he...
Like, the private likes came after because he, like, liked...
I think he liked some really weird shit.
And people were like, bro, what the fuck?
I don't remember what it was.
But, like, I remember the reason why he private likes because he was liking some really fucking weird shit.
So...
He did not like that.
Read Shadow Legends.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
Read Shadow Legends.
That's not 10k.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
And...
When will we be free?
When will...
Honestly, like...
As someone that doesn't really use a lot of social media...
Well, I do...
I do and I don't.
Like, I don't...
You guys know that I don't really tweet a lot in general or, like, reply to many things.
Because, like...
Social media, like, overwhelms me a lot when I have to be, like...
I guess, like, social.
Before I just like to retweet funny memes.
That's really it.
I just like to retweet funny hahas before being a Vtuber.
But, now, obviously, I have to be social because I'm a content creator.
I have to be chronically online.
But I do enjoy.
I do enjoy, like, seeing, like, the fan.
The fan art, the cosplays and everything.
It is very rare for me to interact in general.
Because sometimes I'm like, I don't know what to say.
Like...
I'm just like, I don't know what to say.
Like, oh my gosh, I don't know what to say.
I love lurking.
I love lurking in general.
I'm just really bad at the interacting part.
When I see other vtubers and other content creators replying to almost everything.
I'm just like, how do they do that?
How do they...
Also, how the fuck do they find the time to do that too?
I'm barely surviving right now.
I'm like, how do you find the time to do that?
But I do see it.
I see everything.
I'm just really bad at the interacting part.
I'm just very bad at it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, that's funny.
I remember that.
There was like...
I don't know if you guys remember this.
I don't know if you remember this.
But at one point, there was like a twitter account.
That tracks his private jets movement.
Because he uses the plane.
Almost as much as Taylor Swift does.
Oh no, the Swifties are gonna get it.
Like, are gonna get me now.
Oh no, Toki's gonna get cancelled by the Swifties.
For calling out Taylor Swift and her insane use of the private jet.
Toki, no!
I mean, it's true.
Like...
I mean...
I mean like...
You're gonna deny that?
Like...
You're gonna...
Okay, like I like her music.
But like...
She does not have to use the jet plane.
For those who don't know.
Taylor Swift is very well known.
For using her private jet.
To like travel.
Very small distances.
And by very small distances...
I mean...
Something that could be a...
30 minute car ride.
Like, that's how...
And then she does it...
All the time.
She does it all...
Yes, she flew...
Once within...
The same city.
And I'm like...
Okay, I don't understand this.
Because I don't have a fear of flying.
But like...
You know...
That thought in the back of my head.
If you fly too much.
You know when you're flying too much.
And you're like...
That raises the percentage.
Like...
It's a fucked up thought to have.
But this is why I don't...
That's why I'm like...
How the fuck do you...
Like...
I don't understand.
I fly a lot too.
But like...
I'll be like...
That raises the percentage.
I mean...
So...
It's safer than...
Don't fly.
I don't know.
Well, it's just because there's more...
Okay, the reason why is because there's more...
Fucking cars than there is like...
Planes.
Planes are like...
There's just like...
There's so much...
So many cars.
Okay.
I don't remember which...
Country it was.
But I remember like...
At one point...
It was just too many cars.
That they had to like...
Do a lottery for cars.
Because it was like...
They were trying to get down the pollution.
And also there was too many cars.
That traffic jams was too...
Like it was...
Traffic jams were so bad.
And then there was like...
They wanted to try to get rid...
Like lower the air pollution.
So then like...
Cars became a lottery.
And because there was too many cars.
There were literally too many cars.
And oh yeah, yeah.
And then like...
It's like an Asia thing too.
Where like everyone has a car.
Type deal.
I remember like...
It was like everyone has a car.
Basically.
It's not about like...
The number one thing to own is a car.
Like that's the number one thing to own.
So that's what I'm saying.
That's why the percentage is up.
Because there's a lot.
I'm glad that my work is at home.
I don't think...
I'm really happy that I get to work at home.
And that I live in an area...
Where...
I live in an area...
Where I don't have to worry about driving.
Because everything is just...
Conveniently there.
Or like I'm next to public transport.
Like if I have to...
Or like I just take Uber.
But I try to avoid it.
I try to avoid taking Uber.
Because it's so fucking expensive.
I'm happy to have Uber.
But like...
I try to avoid taking Uber.
Because it's so expensive.
Yes I can drive.
I've talked about this before.
But I do have a license.
I just haven't driven a car in like...
8 plus years.
I don't even...
I keep saying these numbers randomly.
It could be 6, it could be 7, it could be 8.
I just like...
I feel like I have to keep raising the numbers.
Because I don't remember how long it's been since I last drove.
Like I got my driver's license.
And then I stopped.
And then I stopped driving.
That's literally it.
Um...
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As somebody who lives in a city with a minimum 1 hour drive time anywhere.
During my shower, I'd fly.
If I was rich enough.
Thank you.
I just...
I don't know.
I'm not like...
I'm not that big of a fan of...
I think it's because like...
Growing up...
I...
I had to fly a lot.
Back and forth to like...
Visit relatives and stuff.
Or like travel a lot.
So like I had to fly back and forth a lot.
Growing up.
I think I had to fly back and forth at least like...
Uh...
2 to 4 times a year.
Since I was like really, really young.
So because of that...
I think the moment when I...
Like got to go back to Canada.
Um...
When I got to like finally come back to Canada.
For university.
Like I stopped traveling.
Cause like I never...
I got like so...
Like I got so you know...
Um...
I guess like tired of it.
I was just so tired of it.
That I started hating fly...
Like I hated flying and like commuting back and forth.
And like...
Doing those long ass flights.
I just... I can't deal with it anymore.
Um...
It's why like...
When people are like oh do you want to travel around the world?
I'm like fuck no.
I just want to stay at home.
I'm just like...
I got dragged around...
The world a lot growing up.
I'm just...
I'm just tired.
Like...
Don't you want to sightsee?
Don't you want to see all these places?
No I'll just fucking take...
I'll just like...
Watch a video.
I don't care.
I want to...
I want to be at home.
Like...
I remember like...
Cause like...
All those pictures that like...
My family took...
I never look back at it.
So it's like...
I remember...
I remember seeing the leaning tower...
Like the leaning tower of Pisa...
And all that shit.
And all I could think about was like...
God it was so hot and I was so tired.
And then...
I was like...
I remember going to Venice and all I could remember...
Like all I could feel and remember...
Was like...
God it smells so bad.
Because I told you guys...
Like Venice...
The water is not the best.
Like the water.
And I'll be like...
It was like...
I remember when I was at Venice...
I was just like...
It's so crowded and like...
It's so...
Crowded and...
I was just...
It was super crowded...
And long lines...
For like touristy stuff.
And...
And I wasn't...
I didn't have that great of a time.
And then I remember in Paris...
I don't wanna talk...
We don't talk about Paris.
Like...
We all know what happens when...
Tourists go to Paris...
And then they get like culture shock.
Because they're like...
Wait Paris isn't what it's like in the movies?
And then like...
I know there's like an actual...
Like syndrome that you can get from it.
Like the whole culture shock.
Over like how Paris...
Yeah the Paris syndrome.
So like...
There's like a thing called the Paris syndrome.
Where people have to get therapy right after going to Paris.
Because they get so depressed.
That like...
Paris isn't what it was like in the movies and TV shows.
So like...
People have to get therapy right after going to Paris.
So yeah...
No they're right.
Like it's...
And then...
The worst part is that...
I had to go through like...
Um...
Tour guides.
I hate tours.
I know they're like...
We're just trying to make sure you have the most legit experience...
When it comes to visiting these countries.
But like it's such a scam.
I feel like...
They literally take you to places...
That like overcharge you and everything.
Because it's like they take you to the tourist traps.
And then to get like...
Commission fees and all that shit.
And then like...
And then you have to wait for everybody.
Because it's a tour group.
So you have to wait for everybody.
And I'm like...
I just wanna be home.
Oh my god.
And this is why I don't like traveling anymore.
Um...
I'm just very...
I like just being...
I just like...
The experience I like from traveling...
Food.
It's really just food.
Like food...
And yeah that's it.
That's it.
Like I guess like...
Amusement parks and like cute stuff.
Like you know like shopping.
I like shopping for cute things.
And exploring malls.
Or like indoors you know.
Like I'm just thinking about Japan.
Japan I didn't do any really sightseeing.
Because like you know.
Like I said I'm not really into the whole sightseeing part.
I like to shop.
Like buying like cute stuff.
Going to amusement parks.
Going to like Studio Ghibli things.
Cause I was like oh so cute.
And then shopping after that.
Buying like Studio Ghibli stuff.
Or like going to amusement parks and everything.
Like that's fun.
That's fun for me.
I'm not like into the whole like sightseeing stuff in general.
I remember like when I went to like Korea with my friend.
Like we didn't really...
We went to visit one temple.
But that was like the one temple.
Which was like...
This was a long time ago.
But in Seoul.
Where it was like the guy who invented the Korean alphabet.
So like that was like the one sightseeing thing I did.
And other than that we were just like shopping.
And going to like amusement parks.
And like food.
Like that's basically it.
Like I just...
That's like my...
My definition of a good time.
And but yeah.
Not really...
I don't say like a material girl.
Like I don't buy like clothes or anything.
I just buy like...
Oh it's cute you know.
Like I'll be like oh this will look really good.
At my apartment.
Or like oh this looks so cute.
Or like some knick knacks.
And stuff like that.
Like I don't really buy...
I used to have like...
I think this is like an Asian thing too.
Like when I...
When I was back.
Lived in Asia.
It was like a status thing.
To have like designer brands.
And stuff like that.
Because it was like to let people know that yeah.
Like I can...
We have...
So like I learned about like...
Louis Vuitton.
Like Gucci and stuff like that.
But I didn't care.
I didn't care.
I didn't really care.
I just had to have like...
Like I had to have...
Like some form of like...
I had to have at least...
Some form of a designer brand thing.
Because like it was to like...
It was like to upstage like...
Um...
Like my aunties and uncles and stuff.
So like they'll be like...
Yeah she has...
Yeah our daughter has a Louis Vuitton wallet.
I still have a Louis Vuitton wallet.
That was given to me.
Like 10 years ago.
Like I still use it.
Because I...
I don't care that much.
Like...
Um...
Yeah it was like...
It was like...
I guess like Asian flexing and stuff.
Um...
I don't...
I don't buy brand name stuff.
I literally...
My outfits are mostly just like...
Cute sweaters and...
I usually...
Nowadays most of the clothes I buy...
Are...
Most of the clothes I buy...
Are like...
Stuff I buy from like...
I guess like artist alley.
Because it's really cute.
Oh my god!
Like I said yesterday...
When did I went to the fair?
Two days ago?
I was so happy!
Because two days ago I was wearing my cat sweater.
It was very hot.
I'm so...
By the way it was very hot.
I don't like Uniqlo that much.
Um...
I don't know.
I'm not like a huge fan of like...
Uniqlo stuff.
Um...
Because like I don't really like...
I don't like wearing just like...
Graphic t-shirts and stuff like...
I mean like Uniqlo...
I guess there's like other stuff but...
Um...
I don't really like to wear Uniqlo stuff that often.
But like...
I was so happy because I was wearing...
Okay it was really cold in the morning when I went to the fair.
But...
It got hotter so I was like...
I made a mistake.
But...
It was so cute because...
Um...
It was so cute because like...
I was wearing a really cute sweater.
Wait let me see if I can find it.
I think I showed you guys the sweater before.
Um...
And like...
Like a group of girls like...
I was like I love your sweater.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
I feel like my day has been made for the entire day.
Like...
It made me so happy.
Wait let me see if I can find it.
Um...
Fuck where...
I don't even remember what store it was.
Um...
Okay let me see.
Let me see if I can remember what convention...
I got it from.
Fuck okay.
I bought it at an RSLE a long time ago.
So like it's...
So hard for me to remember because it's been a while.
It's been a while.
I remember I showed it to you guys.
Um...
I remember I...
I showed it to you guys before.
It's the one with the lots of cats.
It was the one with...
Lots of cats on it too.
But I can't remember.
I remember I showed it to you guys.
But I don't remember like...
Uh what it looked like.
Maybe I'll...
I remember it had like...
They have a dog version too.
Which was really cute as well.
Uh...
I'm trying to look up artists right now.
I remember I told you guys.
I linked the Instagram and everything.
Cause I was like it's so cute.
Let's see.
Sweaters.
Cute.
Okay.
Wait let me...
I still have like... I have another sweater that I bought.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna find...
I have like one of the sweaters package.
That I haven't opened yet.
Cause like I'm waiting for Gortan to wear it.
I found it.
Okay it's called...
Tanikuma.
Okay.
I don't know.
I really like buying clothes from Artist Alley.
Um...
Cause I don't really care about fashion that much in general.
Uh...
I like looking at really cute fashion but I don't really care about it.
I like looking at it.
I don't like actually...
I guess I just... I don't know.
I just don't like actually wear it.
But I like wearing cute stuff made by other local artists.
Uh...
Oh it's this one.
These are the clothes that I saw.
They're so cute.
And...
Oh I was wearing this one!
Yeah!
This is the one I was wearing.
And the people were like...
The group of girls.
Like group of like... I don't know.
College students I think.
I think they were college...
They're definitely young adults.
Or I don't know.
I can't tell anymore.
Like sometimes like...
They look much older than I expected.
But this is the sweater I had on.
And people were like...
That's so cute!
And I was like...
Yippee!
Oh my god.
But yeah I have several...
I have several apparels and stuff.
Oh my god!
I also have...
Oh my god there's this other...
There's this other really cute...
There's this other really cute clothing shop.
Okay let me see it.
I'm gonna look at what... I'm wearing one right now.
It's a capybara.
Give me a sec.
It's a capybara shirt and it's so cute.
But I don't remember what it's called.
I bought this last year.
Let's see.
Pon...
Sorry I had to take my shirt off.
I had to take my shirt like...
Halfway off to see the label and everything.
Pon...
Let's see.
Is that...
Oh is that it?
Is that her?
No that's not her.
Wait what the fuck is this shop called?
Okay give me a sec.
I need to look at the label.
Did I read it wrong?
I'm reading it upside down.
Um...
Is it not P?
What are you?
On...
Oh Pon Popo?
No I spelled it right.
Pon Popo...
Apparel?
I don't fucking know.
Apparel...
Uh...
No!
What is it called?
Okay.
What is your fucking brand?
Oh there it is!
Okay I found it.
Oh it's Ton Popo!
Ton Popo!
I own this shirt.
I love this shirt.
I...
I have this shirt.
It's...
It's such a cute shirt!
I...
I just think this shirt is really cute.
Like...
I have this shirt.
And I have...
Uh...
Oh my god I wanted to buy everything.
It was so cute.
I have this shirt and I have this one too.
I also own this one as well.
I'm pretty sure I have like a lot more.
But I don't remember what the others were.
But I don't know.
I just like buying clothes from local art...
From artists at Artist Alley.
Or like...
Not just artists from Artist Alley.
But also I like buying clothes from just like local artists.
Because I just really like the designs.
I really like the clothes.
It's like supporting artists and then...
Uh...
Supporting artists and also like...
You know I don't really care much about fashion in general.
And I just think it's cute.
I just think...
Oh yeah and oh my gosh I love her stuff too.
I have like...
I think you guys might know some of their things.
But also...
I'm so excited.
Because like I also bought some like pajama wear from this artist.
Because it's so cute.
The lounge wear.
Oh my god.
I love their lounge wear.
Which one was it?
Which one did I get?
Oh I bought this one.
I bought the...
The starry dream.
And everything.
I bought this one.
From them.
I just thought it was super adorable.
Sorry for all the guys.
I remember...
Speaking of like graphic t-shirts.
Speaking of graphic t-shirts.
I own a Dunder Mifflin graphic t-shirt.
Because I think I was like traveling or something.
I was traveling.
And I forgot to pack an extra shirt.
So I had to like...
Did you guys know?
You can like uber eats shirts.
So like...
It's so embarrassing.
Because like I don't like wearing graphic t-shirts.
Like those types of graphic t-shirts in general.
Yeah you can uber eats like clothes.
Like from like Walmart and stuff like that.
It depends on like what kind of stores are in it.
But like there was a...
I was like okay I need like a shirt.
Like I need like an extra shirt.
So I like...
Because I was like I don't really want to do laundry.
So I'm just going to buy another shirt.
Since I'm traveling.
And I was like well I'm going to be coming home anyway.
Very soon.
But I need an extra shirt.
Before I go out.
For something.
And like obviously I didn't want to wear like my old clothes.
Because I was like I'm going home soon anyway.
So I was like okay I'm just going to uber eats.
I'm going to uber eats a shirt.
And I was looking at it.
And I was so embarrassed.
Because like all the shirt options they have.
I was like...
It was so embarrassed.
There's a Rick and Morty.
I was like alright.
Either I get the Rick and Morty shirt.
The Jurassic.
The Rick and Morty shirt.
Jurassic Park.
Dunder Mifflin.
I don't know.
I was just like oh my gosh.
I'm too old to wear these types of shirts.
Like I...
I was just like oh my god.
I'm not into this.
Oh this wasn't even Jurassic Park.
It was Jurassic World too.
It was like a Jurassic World shirt.
And then...
There was a lot more cringe options.
But like I settled with the Dunder Mifflin.
The Dunder Mifflin.
And the Jurassic World shirt.
I bought two just in case.
Like one was the emergency.
And yeah.
I had to wear...
I didn't wear the Dunder Mifflin.
I was like okay.
If I have to wear either of these in public.
I will wear the Jurassic World shirt.
Because at least people would be like.
Okay.
The Jurassic World shirt.
I was like that's the safest option.
For me.
I don't know.
I feel like not a lot of people wear it.
Maybe they do.
Maybe I just don't go outside anymore.
But like I feel like I don't see lots of people wearing these types of shirts.
Like you know as adults.
I'm so sorry if you're an adult.
And you're wearing a Rick and Morty shirt.
Like I'm really sorry.
But I feel like.
I feel like I don't see that.
Anymore.
Like maybe like five years ago.
Yeah.
But it's definitely not as common.
Anymore.
Like I guess like when you're wearing.
Wearing as like pajamas.
I usually feel like people wear it more as pajamas now.
Instead of like.
Um.
Out in public.
Why do you hurt us like.
I just don't see it as.
As much anymore.
I don't see it.
I wear Fortnite shirts to my university.
Yeah but when you're in university.
Everybody like don't care.
You know what I mean.
Like when you're in university.
Nobody cares what they wear at university.
Because everybody's just trying to survive.
Everyone's just trying to make it through the day.
Um.
Like people even wear like.
Pajamas to classes.
Because they just can't be bothered anymore.
It's more so.
Okay Totoro that's fine.
That's fine.
It's more of like the normie stuff.
You know.
It's more of like the super normie stuff.
That you don't see anymore.
Like I know for sure.
I don't fucking see Dunder Mifflin.
While walking out in public.
Like.
Like I feel like I see more like.
Anime.
Anime stuff.
Than like um.
Than like.
Like normie t-shirts.
Um in general.
But yeah like.
Wait I'm still a member.
That's right Ten.
Wait you're still paying me money.
You never cancelled.
You're still giving me money.
Hahahaha.
CM thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh god.
I saw that once.
I think at university.
I saw that.
I was like alright.
You do you man.
You're not afraid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like.
Ahego hoodies.
You see that more in university.
Than anything else.
Like you'll catch those in the wild.
At university.
Just anywhere else in the world.
That's like.
I don't know why.
But it's like a university outfit.
And I have no idea why it is.
I don't know how it like.
Has got to that point.
Hahahaha.
Where everybody just wears that.
For uni.
Hahahaha.
In high school.
Oh my god speaking of school.
Did you guys know they changed.
How the ABC's are saying now.
You know how like LMNOP.
I like found.
I can't believe I had to find that out.
On a YouTube short.
Hahahaha.
A YouTube short.
Taught me.
That like the new generation of children.
Are taught a different way.
Of singing.
The ABC's.
And it's so weird.
It's so fucking.
Okay I was like.
I like listened to it.
And like caught me off guard.
Cause I was not expecting it.
At all.
Okay ABC song now.
I wonder if I can find it.
Do you know the new alphabet.
Okay let me mute this just in case.
Okay.
Okay I'm listening to this.
I'm checking.
I'm listening to it right now.
They patched it.
Hahahaha.
Okay I'm re-listening to this.
The new alphabet.
Yeah they actually they patched it.
The new patch notes just dropped.
And they removed LMNOP.
How could they.
How dare they.
Why fix not fix.
Urf update.
Patch the alphabet.
This is what it sounds like now by the way.
Um.
Hahahaha.
Girl I like it.
Holy shit.
They patched it after 50 years.
The old song was like fine.
Hahahaha.
The old song was fine.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I mean the kids not wrong.
It's not wrong.
Hahahaha.
Okay yeah this is the full version.
Here for the kids.
L M N O P Q.
What?
It's so oh my god it's so weird.
It's so they actually can't believe it.
It's do you know why?
Do you know why they hotfix.
They patched it.
The new patch notes.
In the.
Hahahaha.
In the earth.
In the 2024 update.
The earth 2024 update patch notes.
So season 2024.
Um so the reason why in season 2024.
They decided to.
Bring out the alphabet patch notes.
Is because.
Is because L M N O P. Was too hard.
Hahahaha.
The fact that they're like.
Bro L M N O P. Was way too hard for the children.
I'm like we all learned L M N O P. All of us.
Nobody had any issue.
Like nobody had any issues.
With L M N O P. Hahahaha.
No I'm not lying it's true.
Like people were like.
Yeah the kids are always stumbling on L M N O P. We might as well like make it easier.
For them.
But L M N O P is the best part.
It literally sounds like.
It's the best part of the alphabet.
I can't even figure it.
That's so dumb.
Hahahaha.
Um.
But yeah I found that out.
On a fucking YouTube short.
And I thought like.
I thought it was a skit.
I didn't realize it was a real thing.
I found that out like last month.
And I was like I kept thinking about it for a long time.
And I keep forgetting to tell you guys about it.
It was an actual skill issue.
It was the Coco Melon.
Dango thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Belargas thank you for the super chat.
The old son discriminating against stupid people.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
That blew my fucking mind.
I was so.
I legitimately just I thought.
I thought it was.
I thought it was fake.
I legitimately thought it was like satire.
From like the onion or some shit.
But it's real.
It's actually real.
The fucking.
Season 2024 update.
Oh my god.
Um.
I wish it was.
Fake.
Um.
I had a hard time.
Like wrapping my head.
At the thought that like LMNOP.
Literally doesn't exist anymore.
Alright thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They thought LMNOP was too OP.
So they literally dropped it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
But yeah it's.
It's pretty crazy.
Um.
Everyone thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Hot take from a former teacher.
But the best way of teaching language.
Was settled like 60 years ago.
But tech pro mentality makes people think.
We need change for the sake of change.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
But yeah it's really interesting though.
That's like really interesting.
Do you guys also know you can order a house from Amazon?
I love capitalism.
Like.
You can't afford a house anymore?
Fucking order a house from Amazon.
Yeah you guys know that?
You can literally buy a house for like $2000.
I think.
Maybe more I don't remember.
Maybe $2000 American.
Alright house.
I'm looking up a house.
Yeah you can literally order a house right now.
Like you can literally order.
I don't know if it's like exclusive to like America.
Okay.
Order a house on Amazon.
Yeah you just assemble it.
Yeah.
Oh nevermind it's like $7000 Canadian.
Like I mean it's still the same.
Oh no.
Let's see.
It's like $7000 Canadian.
The cheapest one.
Oh my god.
There's so many choices.
I like how the majority of them are like one star.
I'm like.
I'll give you guys the.
The Amazon.com version.
But yes.
Here you guys go.
You can literally order a house on Amazon.
And then assemble it yourself.
I actually.
I'm curious.
Like.
Here you go.
This is what it is.
Thank you for coming to AMG.
First time I ever got to join a meet and greet.
Fuck waffle and LMNOP is actually different in Australia.
Thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you for very first magenta soupa too.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, there's literally one person at least bought it.
Guys, there's only five left and who the fuck spent $48,000?
What the fuck?
Somebody spent $48,000 on a...
I want to know what his...
Okay, picture does not match the real price.
Okay, apparently the picture is not what the house actually looks like.
Oh my god, to that one guy that ordered the $48,000 house.
Oh, somebody gave it five stars for this $5,000 house.
What does it say?
It is so cool.
Thanks Brandon for...
Wait, is this a YouTuber?
What the fuck?
Is this...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
No, it's not.
It's a founder.
Bro, somebody liked it.
Somebody from the United States liked this folding prefab house.
Yeah, you can literally...
If you guys want to buy a house...
Somebody left six ratings for this 40 feet tiny house to live in?
Oh my god.
Who did this?
Very good.
Awesome house for the price.
You just need to find a good space of land and you're all set.
Just plan it out and make sure...
Whoa!
A lot of people like it.
Easy to install.
I don't...
Wait, I don't like this.
Okay.
I don't want to...
This guy actually has his real name.
Wait, I like this review.
I think this is my favorite review out of all of them.
Okay.
I'm going to save this real fast.
I actually...
I made sure to like hide the name because I actually think that's his real name.
And he put his real name in the review.
I like this review.
Easy to install.
I didn't buy it, but it looks easy.
That's crazy.
It's actually crazy that you can buy a house now.
It's fucking wild.
Oh my God.
But yeah, that's basically what...
Oh yeah.
I mean, 110 people were super curious about buying a house, you know, and they were all super curious being like, whoa.
I wonder what that's like.
Yeah.
Like being able...
I was just wondering how do you deliver that?
Like deliver a house over?
Like, oh my God.
Like that has to be a separate thing.
Like a separate delivery truck that's sending it over.
Like how, like how does that work?
I don't understand.
All right.
I'm looking at my amazon.ca prefab house now.
I want to know, can I prime it?
Is there, is there...
There's no prime.
What's the point?
What's the point if I don't have Amazon?
Amazon Prime for my... if I don't have... if I can't Amazon Prime my house.
Like, what's the point?
Where's my one-day shipping, Amazon?
Where is it?
No same-day shipping?
What a fucking scam.
Oh my god, the fastest is September 4th?
I can literally get a house on September 4th.
Holy shit.
Guys, you know how you're always saying I should buy a house?
I just...
It's only 7k and it comes with a bathroom.
Chat.
This is some otherworlds dystopian shit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You guys always tell me to buy a house.
It's literally 7k and it comes with a bathroom.
Guys.
Boss, you don't have land.
It's okay, I can rent land.
I'll just live in the woods.
There must be some form of land that I can rent.
Everyone rents.
You guys said I should start buying a house.
You never said I should...
You never said I should buy land.
Sean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If Jeff Bezos can't deliver my prefab house via Choreodrone, then what is the point?
What's the point?
Thank you for the super chat, Sean.
Thank you.
That's true, though.
What's the point if they can drone my house over?
They can just attach... it can be like Up where they attach like a thousand drones on the house and it just flies over.
By the way, I talked about this before, but you can Airbnb literally the house of Up.
Which is... I still think that's fucking crazy.
That's the thing.
That's...
Oh my god, did you guys see that?
It's so... okay.
Since we're talking about dystopian shit.
Did you guys see that tweet of the Deadpool actor at Disneyland making a joke about the Disney plus TOS?
Like, holy fuck.
It's just like... bro, that's so fucked.
I was like, yeah, like... that's so fucked.
That's so dystopian.
I was just like, bro, like, there's no way.
I was like, no, that dude definitely lost his job for that.
There's no way that was approved.
There's no fucking...
No, it was like... it was like at Disneyland and like he made a joke about the Disney plus TOS.
And I'm like, at Disney World.
Bro, the fucked up...
No, the reason why it's so fucked up is because the whole incident happened in Disney World.
Like...
It's like, bro, that is like so fucked.
Oh my god.
Oh...
And people were like...
Holy shit.
To be fair, I don't know if you guys know this, but working in Disneyland slash Disney World is really bad.
Like, it's... I don't know if you guys...
Oh no, Disney's gonna get you.
Like, everybody's talked about this, but like...
I don't know if it improved.
I don't know if it improved, but the old Disney program...
I heard about, like, the Disney program.
And, like, working at Disneyland and Disney World is really bad.
It's worse than, like...
The actual minimum wage jobs.
Like, people would be like...
Ah, like, yeah, it's my dream come true to...
work at Disneyland and everything.
But it's literally one of the worst jobs you can get.
Because...
Like, you know...
Like, overheating and stuff like that.
Working outside for...
I work at Disneyland...
Its, smile...
Oh...
It's actually not a great job.
The thing is, it's because they take advantage of the workers.
Because they're like, oh, I just want to work at Disney because it's my dream.
My dream to work with Disney, you know?
So they take advantage of the Disney magic.
And then that's how they hook you.
And then you actually work there.
And then you're like, wait, this is actually a terrible job.
It's basically like...
Yeah, that's what somebody said.
It's like working a minimum wage job.
But then you have to have the credentials of PhD people or something.
And you barely get paid anything.
You barely get paid anything to fucking survive.
But this is like... I don't know if it's the same for other Disney lands and different countries.
But this is what I know about America.
This is what I know about Disney land.
No, but then that's basically any job.
Yeah, but the rules are more strict.
I don't know.
Have you guys...
Okay, I read an article about Disneyland worker rules.
The rules...
Because you have to uphold the Disney magic.
And so they make sure that the rules are incredibly strict.
Just so like...
Just so you have to like...
Because you have to keep up the Disney magic and everything.
You can't... Okay, like, let me look through it.
This is funny.
They aren't allowed to say, I don't know.
Like, what the fuck?
They're not...
You're not allowed to say, I don't know.
You have to have an answer to everything.
That's so fucking weird.
Like...
That's so...
You have...
Yeah, I know that you have to be in character.
Nothing exists outside of Disney.
What the fuck?
For cast members playing characters, they must act like nothing exists out of the Disney universe.
Oh my God.
Don't break character.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, there are requirements.
I know about that.
But it's like super strict.
Everything.
They can't fangirl.
The talking code.
I know that.
Oh, yeah.
Social media posts are a no-no.
So, you're not allowed to talk about...
You're not allowed...
They can't point.
Oh, yeah.
They can't point also.
Because pointing is offensive in some parts of the world.
So, they can't point or anything.
And you can't post anything about being a Disneyland worker.
Like, publicly.
Or anything.
Let's see.
Wait, they can't bend down?
Wait, is that true?
There's no way.
They can't bend down and pick it off the ground.
That would...
What?
That would be too obvious and take guests out of the moment.
Instead, cast members have to use the swoop and scoop motion...
to gracefully remove garbage from the ground.
What the fuck?
What the fuck does that rule?
Oh, my God.
That's...
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait.
This is funny.
Someone was like, when I was there, they had a rule of no dating other cast members.
Like...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Let's see.
What else?
Don't raise your hands if you're tall.
Don't do it.
What?
What the fuck does that mean?
No dating.
Guest out.
Oh, my God.
Mickey can't date Minnie Mouse?
Like, how does that happen?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
But what about Mickey and Minnie?
Following the five keys.
Wearing it.
Yeah.
Saying I don't know.
Let's see.
Protecting the magic.
Yeah.
It's actually crazy.
Like, the...
It's just incredibly strict for the Disney workers.
It's incredibly strict for the fact that you don't get paid much, like, for something like that.
Because you have to protect the magic.
You have to protect it.
So, you have to get new glasses.
You'll never see...
Oh, I mean, that's true.
All glasses must be conservative in color and design, which isn't too big.
I guess because they want everybody to have the same type of glasses.
So, like, everybody, like, basically looks the same type deal.
So...
So, I guess that makes sense, you know?
I guess that makes sense because they don't want people to...
They won't want people to, like, look, like, too flashy or anything.
That's such a weird rule.
It does...
It does feel like a weird rule, though.
There's Disney University?
This isn't a guideline so much as a requirement.
New employees must attend what is known as a Disney University for classes in which they learn everything there is to know about Disney's history and magic.
They first must attend a traditional orientation which runs through all the basics.
It's where the employment journey begins.
What the fuck do you learn at Disney University?
There's Disney College?
Alright.
Formerly known as the University of Disneyland is the global training program for employees at the par...
Holy fuck!
I didn't even know this exists.
They have to learn...
Wait!
There's Disney University!
What?
Okay.
I didn't know what you learned there.
What do you learn at Disney University?
The Disney College program.
The whole...
There's housing!
Wait!
It's actually...
There's college credit!
Oh, it doesn't...
The Disney Ice...
Okay.
Even I didn't know about the Disney University.
That...
That's funny.
That's fucked up.
But that's funny.
Wait!
Don't tell me that's a real thing.
Please tell me you're fucking with me.
Oh my god!
There's a hamburger university?
Holy shit!
Wait!
Is there a university for every major corporation?
Is that real?
There's a hamburger university.
The more you know.
Tuition is $48,000 per semester?
There's no way.
You have to be fucking with me.
I need to look that up.
How much is tuition?
Tuition.
There's no way.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Upon acceptance.
Okay.
It's not bad.
It's like around...
Guys, it's not bad.
Guys.
It's like $240 for program fees.
You know, this is actually...
Oh, wait.
This is pretty good.
It's $455, guys.
If you guys want to go...
Guys, afford...
You know what?
Despite everything I've said...
At least it's affordable.
You know?
At least it's not like...
Like hundreds of thousands of dollars a day.
At least it's affordable.
At least...
I'll just say that.
$450?
Like...
For the entire semester?
That's pretty affordable.
For this university.
Like...
Like in America.
No.
You guys have to know.
If we're doing...
For those...
It's not affordable on a Disney salary.
The fact that you have to get another...
You have to get a part-time job to like be able to afford the Disney University because you can't make enough under the Disney...
Under working for Disneyland to pay for the program.
That's the fucked up part.
That's not...
Not a part.
For those who are like, $40 is a lot.
You guys don't understand.
American universities...
I know like in Europe...
It's crazy.
I know it's really crazy for some Americans to know this.
But in Europe...
Sometimes...
In Europe, the government sometimes pay you to go to university.
Which is pretty fucked up when you compare it to American university.
Where like...
It's very expensive.
Yeah.
So a lot of like...
I like how some Americans are like, wait, really?
Yeah.
So like in Europe, there's some European countries.
That literally pay...
That literally like...
Pay the...
Pay people to go to their university.
And then I know like in Australia, I don't know if they changed it.
But in Australia, basically, like you go to university and the government pays for it.
And if you make...
If you graduate university and make enough money, like enough money...
Like they give like a certain point where if you make that much money...
You have to pay back the...
Pay back the tuition.
But if you don't make that much money on your job...
After you graduate university, you don't have to pay for the tuition.
You don't have to pay for your university.
In Australia.
So like that's what I know.
But yeah, I know like...
Although like a lot of European countries pay for students to go to university and stuff.
Which is fucking crazy to think about.
That's cheating.
I'm sold moving there now.
I know how you guys are like, I'm sold.
I'm going to move there.
Like how somebody said taxes are a lot more expensive.
Taxes are...
Taxes are crazy though.
So it's basically like you have to remember.
You're going to...
The reason why they can do that is because taxes are really bad.
They're not really bad.
I'm not saying taxes are bad.
I'm not committing tax fraud.
I'm saying that it's a lot more than what we're used to.
Like in NA.
It's a lot more than what we're used to in NA.
Let's see.
Sean.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi people who think $450 university education is a lot.
I paid $30,000 for mine and mine is not even the worst.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
But yeah.
That's...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Somebody...
How much is a Disney college?
Oh, somebody is...
Wait.
There's a Reddit.
There's literally a subreddit for the Disney college program.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
It feels so dystopian.
Because it feels like...
Like...
Like the Disney college program.
Um...
Oh my God.
This is actually feels like Disney adults like applying for this shit.
But like...
Like the fact that there's a Disney college program subreddit makes it feel like...
You know how like students are asking in subreddit about like...
Oh my God.
Like...
Um...
Has anyone heard about the acceptance letter from Harvard yet?
Like...
On the Harvard subreddit.
Like this is what it feels like.
I'm reading the Disney college program subreddit right now.
And then one of the posts was like...
Um...
Did anybody hear back from the...
From their interviews yet?
Like...
Oh my God.
They're like...
I'm still waiting for my phone interview.
And I'm like...
Oh my God.
You poor...
You poor souls.
Like...
Oh my God.
You poor...
You poor souls.
Oh my God.
This...
I don't know.
I...
You have to do well my friend.
You're cannot save them...
You can't save...
They...
Hey, they've already... they're way too far gone.
They're way too far gone.
Like, I'm sorry.
Like, it's so pessimistic, but, like, I feel like it's so...
Like, listening to, like, the stories about, like, working for Disneyland and, like...
Like, Disneyland and Disney World, it sounds like...
Like, the fact that, like, it's very... it's just not a good time for, like, the amount of money you're being paid.
Like, just for the... the amount of money that you're paid for the work is just not... it doesn't sound great.
Oh, my God.
Anyway.
Anyway, that's my...
That's my yap session.
That's my yap session for today, guys.
We're...
If I never am allowed to play Disney games ever again, you know why.
They're gonna look at this particular stream.
Also, I think Avatar World and Disneyland fucking is so fucking stupid.
That's my last take on...
I think that's a waste of land.
Who the fuck wanted Avatar World?
Like, who the fuck wanted that?
I mean, it's not even that good of a movie.
Like...
Like, no, the lore and everything.
You know they're planning on making Avatar World in, like, a different Disneyland?
Who the fuck wants that?
Nobody cares.
Like, nobody cares about Avatar World, Pandora, the world of Avatar.
Like...
It's such...
It's so stupid.
Nobody cares about the...
The world of Avatar.
Like...
Nobody wants to...
I just feel like...
I just feel like that was such a waste of money.
Like, I...
I would want other worlds.
Like...
Oh, my God.
Like, build a fucking...
Build, like...
I don't know.
Like...
Honestly, they could choose any other world.
They could literally choose any other world.
But they decided to pick...
Pandora.
The world of Avatar.
Like...
I...
I'm gonna say it.
The first movie...
Insulting my favorite movie feels bad.
Thank you for the super chat, Snooks.
Thank you.
Did you not see...
Okay.
I haven't...
I saw, like, the...
I saw the ride...
The...
The ride with, like...
They're like, oh, this is, like, the most expensive animatronic so far.
Like, the...
Um...
What was it?
One of the Na'vi or whatever.
And then, like, that was, like, the only good portion.
Um...
The only good portion.
It's actually a very popular world.
I would feel like the Star Wars world, um, is more popular than Pandora.
Like, nobody really talks about, like, Pandora.
I feel like...
I feel like nobody really talks about the world of Pandora.
I don't even know.
I don't even know the lore.
Like...
I barely know the lore about the world of Pandora.
What the fuck?
It's the world where...
The only reason why I remember Pandora is because...
Okay, to be fair, like, they already milked Star Wars so hard that, like, it's dead now.
Um...
But other than that, like...
Like...
I just feel like...
Nobody really...
I don't even know what the second movie is about.
Like, I don't even...
And then they're making a third movie.
I know, like, the second movie is about, like...
What was his name?
Jake?
That's his name, right?
Jake's kids or whatever.
But, like, that's the...
I didn't even watch the second movie.
I watched the first movie because at that time it was, like, FOMO and everybody watches...
Everybody, um, watched Avatar.
Um...
I liked how because, like, Disney got Avatar...
That they copyrighted trademarked Avatar...
That Avatar the Last Airbender cannot be called Avatar.
Only Avatar anymore.
They have to be called Avatar the Last Airbender because Disney trademarked Avatar.
I think that's pretty funny.
Oh, my God.
Um...
But, yeah.
I...
I don't know.
I just feel like...
I feel like Pandora was just...
I don't know.
I just feel like Pandora is not, like, a cool world to have.
Like, I...
There's so many...
Like, there's so many, like, so cool Disney world...
Like, Disney, like, worlds they can, like, make into, like, an area.
Um...
And the fact that, like...
I just feel like Pandora is just not, like, the best choice...
Like, to have.
Like...
It's just...
I feel like...
Like, immersion-wise, they could have chose anything else for immersion-wise.
I just didn't think Pandora was the right choice.
I felt like they could have picked anything else.
Um...
Let's see.
What else do I...
Okay.
Before...
I'm sorry.
I'm roasting everything regarding Disney.
I love Disney, by the way.
Like, I love their movies.
I love...
I...
I love their...
I love their movies.
Well, their old movies.
Their...
Their classics.
Their classic animated films.
Like, we don't talk about current Disney.
But, I like their classic films.
But...
Like, I have to criticize it because it's just not the same anymore.
It's...
It's just not the same anymore.
Um...
It's...
The reason why I'm so passionate about, like, some of my hate towards the stuff they do...
Is because I love Disney so much that I...
I don't like how...
What modern Disney has become.
Also, fuck Disney for shutting down Disney.
I don't like?
Well, Disney is amazing...
Yeah, well you know, I don't like theDisney eats, like...
You know that Disney is the best in this country.
You know this is the movie made of only...
Yeah, sure, it's a fucking shit movie.
But it's, you know...
It's so good.
But, yeah.
dor Europa, this is the worst movie I have ever seen.
I mean, seriously.
Oh God, oh God.
You know this...
The one thing that justしく changed my opinion is...
Well.
That Schwangerran will be.
I would always be mad.
I would be mad.
Oh my god, there was something else I wanted to talk about.
Is it about Disney?
Oh yeah, it's about amusement parks.
I know, like I said, I'm going to end it here.
But did you guys see that they're going to make a Dragon Ball Z world?
But I thought the funniest shit was that it's not going to be in Japan, but it's going to be in, like, Saudi Arabia.
I thought... The fact that, like, the Dragon Ball Z... Yeah, they're going to make Dragon...
They're going to make an amusement park based off of Dragon Ball Z.
Like, literally based off...
It's going to be in Saudi Arabia.
And, like, it's so crazy because they're... You know where it's going to be?
They're going to carve the desert.
I was so... They're going to fucking carve the desert to fit...
Like, to fit... Yeah, they're going to... It was... It was in... It was in...
It was... I saw it on a YouTube short and it was like...
Yeah, they're... Because it's not just going to be... Okay, wait.
I need to, like, look at...
I saw it on a YouTube short and I was like, what the fuck?
There's no way.
It's going to be... It's going to be in fucking Saudi Arabia?
Like...
I was so surprised.
I was like, here, here's the teaser.
I saw the teaser.
So, they released the teaser for it.
And this was it.
Is it this?
Oh, yeah.
So, this is basically...
This is a teaser for the world.
And it's not just that.
There was, like...
There's, like, so many.
They're planning on making, like, different...
Oh, yeah.
They're making a Six Flags, too.
They're making a... They're making a Six Flags.
Oh, it's going to be next to the Dragon Ball Z world.
Because they're working on Six Flags right now.
They're working on that right now.
And then after Six Flags, they're going to work on... They're going to do the Dragon Ball Z area.
But I thought it was so funny that, like...
Six Flags is going to be in Saudi Arabia next to the Dragon Ball theme park.
I just thought that was so interesting.
Yeah, there's going to be a Six Flags.
Yeah, anyway.
Why not make the world a Kingdom Hearts?
Oh, they're dressing up as...
They're dressing up as Kingdom Hearts right now.
And then some... I saw somebody on Twitter, like, posted a picture of it.
Because they didn't know... They don't understand Kingdom Hearts.
And they're like, why did they give Mickey a sword?
I saw that on Twitter.
It's so funny.
Because every Halloween, they bring out Kingdom Hearts.
They bring out Kingdom Hearts during Halloween for Disneyland.
And so, like, they dress them up.
So, like, you know, Donald, Goofy, and Mickey, and Sora.
We don't talk about the Sora.
The Sora...
Oh, my God.
Sora looks...
Because, like, the thing is, for Sora, for Kingdom Hearts meet and greets in Disneyland or Disney World, they may give him, like...
It's not...
They make him a mascot.
It's so ugly.
It's actually...
They don't make him, like, a person.
They give him, like...
This is what...
Okay, I'll show you guys.
Like...
I don't know.
It looks...
It's just so...
Uncanny.
It's...
It's so uncanny.
I can't...
It's so weird.
I don't like it.
Okay, I'll show you guys a picture.
I don't think they bring him out anymore.
Because people complain too much.
People were like, no, he's too much of a freak right now.
Like, we shouldn't bring him out anymore.
Whatever.
Did I download it?
Oh, did I not download it?
Where did I...
Oh, I put it in my thumbnails.
Oh my gosh, I'm going to delete that after...
I put it in my thumbnails.
This is what he looks like.
He looks a little freaky.
Like, it's just so uncanny.
Just make him a real...
Just give him a fake...
Like, I don't know.
Just don't put a mask on him.
Let's go...
Speaking of Halloween, though.
Did you guys know, like...
You can be a skibbity toilet now for...
I don't know.
But for like...
What was it called?
The Halloween store?
The Halloween popup store?
Oh, my God.
Spirit Halloween!
Oh, my.
There's some crazy costumes at spirit Halloween now!
Yeah.
No.
You...
There's some fucking crazy costumes at spirit Halloween!
But some of them, I was...
I was not...
Okay.
I was...
I was very surprised that some of the stuff...
Oh yeah, by the way, like, you can... the amazing digital circus is in it, too.
Um... the amazing... they have costumes from the amazing digital circus.
I... it's just crazy to think about that, like, stuff like these are costumes now.
Like, no, it's true!
I saw it on Twitter.
It's true.
I wish I was joking.
Let me see if I can find it.
I'm gonna see if I can find it.
Um, alright.
I'm looking at Spirit Halloween right now.
It was literally, like, someone took a picture of it, and I was like, what the fuck?
There's no... I was like, what the fuck?
This is real.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh yeah, they...
Wait, they have... wait, they have a Nezuko costume at Spirit Halloween?
Holy fuck, okay.
I mean, good for you.
Good on, I guess.
Good for you for the branding and everything.
Is that the only anime thing they have?
There's no way.
What, really?
Oh my god, it is.
It's, like, the only anime thing they...
Oh my god, you keep picking something!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Why is that there?
Why is... why is the Fal'Guard Sonic the Hedgehog in there?
Oh my god.
Okay, that one was good.
That one...
I did not expect that to be a costume, not gonna lie.
I... I was not... I was not expecting that.
Um...
Like, for Fall guys too, like that's so specific.
That is such a specific costume.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
Here you go.
Here you go, guys.
For those who wanted to know what that looked like, don't worry, I got you guys.
It's called Kid's Inflatable Skibbity Toilet Costume.
It's literally in Spirit Halloween right now.
I've even posted... Okay, let's see.
I'll put it up on screen too for you guys.
Just for all of you guys.
Alright.
Okay, look.
This is a Halloween costume now.
Holy shit.
We live in the timeline where this is a Halloween costume.
Alright.
I'm calling it for real now.
Oh, I found this one's pretty funny too.
Okay, before I call it for real, I thought this was a...
This was a very silly costume.
I...
I thought this was pretty funny.
It's called Adult Bee Stinger Costume.
Um...
Alright, I'm calling it for real this time.
I just want to end it with that costume.
Because I thought it was pretty silly.
Um...
Because Halloween is coming up.
Anyway, guys.
Alright, I'm going to call it here.
It's fun chatting with you guys as always.
I love hanging out with my dragons.
And just...
Uh...
And just like talking with you guys.
And having...
Thanks, Toki.
I hate it.
Thank you for the super chat, Mr. Tooth.
Thank you.
Um...
But I always love chatting with you guys.
I hope you guys enjoyed talking with me.
Yapping with me.
Uh...
I went through a bunch of topics.
Um...
So I hope you guys had a great rest of your day.
Or a good night for you guys.
Or a good morning for those who are just waking up.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.